che sabato è se non faccio la intro dopo
un minuto che mi sono svegliato non ne
sarebbe sabato quindi bella a tutti
ragazzi venuti a questo nuovo video sono
fa vj e allora seriamente solo per darmi
una roba velocissima però volevo dirvelo
e diciamo che io non sono stato proprio
madonna quanto ciò che gli occhiali e
stamattina
adesso scusate suo mood vabbè tanto non
sono youtuber esperto io scherzando
prendo in giro pietro in tutti i modi
possibili no ed era spopolata sta roba
del pietro again o che è andata tanto
perché io lo prendevo in giro ma
comunque gay non è neanche un insulto
che quando dicono favi gay
cioè non penso che nessuno sia mai
sentito offeso la parola gay
vabbè parma a parte quello ho esagerato
un pochettino perché comunque pietro è
una persona da quel momento da quando io
vado ai raduni tutti quanti tutti si
presentano la scritta pietre gay che
faceva ridere all'inizio però dopo è
diventata un po non va bene questa cosa
comunque sia c'è io lo prendo in giro ma
perché mio amico voglio dire se in conto
è se lo faccio io un conto se lo fanno
gli altri quindi se vedete pietro in
giro la gente li va lì e dice ciao
pietro sei gay ragazzo davvero non fate
ste stronzate nello scherzo quando io
dico anche voi scherzate ovvio però io
lo conosco i no io ho esagerato e chiedo
scusa sono serio cioè vive veramente
esagerato e chiedo scusa se la cosa è
sfuggita di mano perché non avevano
minimamente intenzione di di mortificare
una persona anche perché comunque io lo
prendo in giro come amico voglio dire
che per me io li voglio un sacco bene ci
mancherebbe altro quindi detto questo io
volevo fare un video in questo 2017 dove
abbiamo passato gli sto facendo solo
best of perché non so di che cazzo fanno
non è vero che ero fuori casa in vacanza
quindi ho deciso di fare un best of the
move e kiko pietro appunto che non ha
veramente senso a niente spero vi
piaccia buona visione
tempo porca vacca si muove di raucci la
senti l'ultimo tra dovuto fare io ho
dovuto fare io perchè non non c'era
nessuno qua a casa mia
adesso ci sei tu quello stava
giallorosso va bene va bene
mussini mettilo qua
mettilo su questo punto qui così bravo
bravo esatto esatto bravissimo bavagli
si uso ma chi non l'hai fatto per
avremmo visto questo goloso ma chi
insomma sopra vado anche in hope that my
via tanto non ti voleva nessuno anche
prima non riesci incazzato se non sei
capace di contare allora non cominciare
nemmeno noi siamo capaci ma sappi che in
ogni caso sei sempre stupito al cento
per cento mediana da un po di spinta che
conoscete mai visto qualcosa
bravo secondo me a bagnarlo un po poi
bagnano vediamo un po che succede
corsero bagniamo no no no
e difficilissimo e non dirlo a me anche
a chi al casinò come faccio
ci sono anch'io del gioco no è solo
preso comiti sicuro progaming ho fatto
una finta non è che è difficilissimo
dobbiamo fare dei bei disegni
vince delle guance ma dalla contenuti
nocivi
vabbè allora la macchina maglia dalmazzo
infinito in questi interessi ma li stai
vedendo al pocho il foglio quasi non
solo una banana storia castro gioco di
miccoli quel coso bello youtubers smash
allora ci sono due youtube grazie hanno
degli iscritti e tu devi dire che ne so
pietro faringei chi ha più iscritti o vi
avesse bullismo
se viene verso di me io fila la
videocamera attuate la lana fai cagare
io ti giuro in questo gioco non so ma
proprio di schiaffino nido non sono
capace che non fai video educativi per i
ragazzi sbattere contro alberi
cartelloni valicabile telamonio tele
forza capire la vicenda di una prova
nella sua capacità cabine telefoniche
mentre cammini o'shea mentre ci sarei
morta cammino una volta si vantava di
qua
ma quella volta che sei così allora
sbattere contro alberi internet e
spazzato di troll
credo che internet è pieno di trofei ma
la tua connessione internet inizia
sempre chiare corre la mamma degli
haters speriamo qualcuno che picchiava
la porta come se non ci fosse un domani
realtà potrebbe essere la mente così
sì perché potrebbe lasciare i militari
sono i militari abbiamo me ne vado non
ci credeva
ma don pietro anime che tris entrare in
una lotta pietro li uccide trionfalmente
entrambi pietro vince gli hunger games
per primo il tuo pietro no vedo di
chiamare taglia non ci credo non mi caga
è vietato un bip adesso che abita fatti
i soldi bastard e vi sarebbe un charlie
stare lassù già venduta in jump ok ok
little on the left penali dell on the
left non jumping gioco
bebe 9 quickly and will i.am detto no
perché se mi vedi qui non cambia le cose
sai ridurre a rischio
ricapitolando su quello che abbiamo
fatto abbiamo dell'ottimo hosomaki ben
chiuso vedo però ci siamo impegnate mi
può scegliere il sacerdote da dio
il sashimi e per federer è dei migliori
che sembrano dei ritiri con dei problemi
però intanto c'è lo sponsor perché già
trovarmi esatto chiamare la tua ragazza
come lei finale no no a max e raggiungi
la bravo
pistonami ti giuro che ti si è
schiantato sul muro non hai visto
puoi scappare chiunque graficamente la
stazione
nessuno ti amerà mai ma faccio lunghezze
e se sotto per 109 che peccato
gli avrebbe sono veramente lì così come
sono ma chiava numero di youtube
italiani messi a confronto chiede
iscritti tra i due alla smettiamo mezzi
o hai vinto gli hunger games come ci si
sente adesso è una bella versione grazie
vita della media niente trova impegnato
dei paparazzi scusate ho capito vorrei
ancora adesso stronzo sono andando
avanti veloce per vedere chi muore chi
vince ancora e presidi 1 in finale
pietro incredibile perché lupa pietro
puglia non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere
basta caso vince e basta fatta vittoria
per pietro molavi chiamo lui ci si sente
aver vinto di voi hunger games amico ti
voglio bene mamma
ciao amici io sono alla città
non importano 6 a scuola in gol ma sei
scemo
ciao sappiamo i cannoli forti gli uomini
grazie perché io sono una persona brava
che stai cercando te la posta siamo
tutti youtube ed etero prefetto non
mollare mai tarzan la memoria di spinta
più spinta più speed perfetto 6 in
verticale lasciate mare ai riflessi di
un brontosauro morto e cieco abiti non
aspetta qualcosa o i baffi ora marino no
dai
hey hey hey pratica e non per questo
obiettivo sì ma come si sa i sei
meravigliosa di add on
io ti giuro in questo gioco non sono ma
poiché rischia fino a lì da homo euro
mousse in their